hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
heute zu einem neuen video namens
gedacht ich muss noch passt irgendwie
noch bei wir wissen nicht was das
bringen wir gedacht wir setzen uns
einfach zu fünf vor die kamera und
machen was wir machen ein paar stunden
später
wir machen zum fünfjährigen papieren der
verlierer muss den rest das nicht alles
trinken stirbt mittrinken die nicht mehr
als einen kleinen schluck wein sterben
wie viel gehalt aufgebaut die da vorne
und ich sag mal was die schulen die
ganze zeit gefilmt
was haltet ihr eigentlich solche videos
die herren stellen und seines schwarzen
draußen
ich habe den papiere gurkenscheiben so
sind die idee kam mir ein wort kommen
wir machen schule stand habe ich mich
noch nicht
die kamera steht gerade auf dem dach ich
entschuldige mich an dieser stelle
dieses video aber ich dachte so lässt
sich einfach mal kamera aufzustellen ich
guck mal alle komisch an schere stein
papier um rasierschaum mono brauche ich
habe angst sicher paranoia vorausschau
auf dem boden verlieren
ich schwöre ich hätte papier
da hat meine faire okay aber auch dass
bei den nachbarn und den dass du schwarz
sieht ich schwöre ich hatte echt papier
ich schwöre wirklich bin
bitte geh ich wichtig wenn ich die mono
brauche ich schwöre es euch echt kein
scheiß
wir schlafen wir haben manchmal machst
du also bevor ironische weise abgehoben
seine chance gewartet waren wir dort
dabei zu entscheiden sie was wir schon
morgen macht wieder aufgenommen auf den
kopf geschossen haben
hollaender ein paar sekunden später
dazu gehöre nur auf den augenbrauen
dass ich jetzt geschnitten und ich weiß
jetzt nicht was das war wir haben halt
uns gedacht ja auch wir nehmen eine
kamera und filme in las vegas machen und
da man irgendwie scheiße war deswegen
zwar ein bisschen cool findet